get dressed and put on your creepy
animal mask because we have tree house
the latest episode and who lose into the
dark series and this one has souffles I
mean chocolate things for women tree
house follows Peter Ramsey I mean break
a celebrity chef needing some fresh
country air and time to work on his new
cookbook or at least that's what he
tells his sister Gwen but to truly
understand the ending of tree house we
must first look at where Peters
character starts and how the events of
the film change him and his outlook on
life Peter is a straight-up dick he
treats the maid Agnes like [ __ ] makes
fun of Lonnie relentlessly and we learn
he wasn't even welcomed at his father's
funeral more importantly he's so busy he
doesn't have time to hang out with his
daughter but even that being the case we
do get a sense that he loves her his
famous restaurant and cutlery line is
named after her and he tells her she's
his only and that he needs her that
being said Peter is still self-centered
thinking only about himself and it won't
be until he goes through this journey
with the quote/unquote witches that he
will truly change as a man but the event
that spurred this entire story is hinted
at in the very first scene we get a
glimpse of a woman will come to learn is
Becca wheeler she's having a picnic
holding one of Peters knives in her hand
later we'll find out that the painting
in the main foyer is of her as well a
painting supposedly done by Peter's
father who'd like to paint subjects that
capture quote the fragility of life it's
only when Peter is drugged by Agnes and
held captive by the women that we learn
what this story is really about revenge
for the way Peter has treated women
throughout his life specifically Becca
who he raped in the treehouse and not
only that smeared her name in the papers
when the allegations came out no one
believed Becca and she turned to heroin
to numb the pain you can see the needle
marks here and she eventually slit her
wrists with Peters own cutlery but it
wasn't just this instance Marie and
Lilith reenact for him the time he made
unwanted advances on a journalist yet he
still doesn't see the error of his ways
making excuses that she was asking for
and leading him on by agreeing to meet
him at a bar
she said exclusive for weeks she met me
at a bar told us to meet you then even
when Peter is confronted in the car by
his own sister who we later find out is
in on the whole scheme he dismisses
Becca's rape as him just being a stupid
drunk teenager for Peter nothing is his
fault and he'll say or do anything to
save his own ass it's only when the
witches perform their final ritual that
Peter wakes up a changed man
he has been scared so deeply that it has
essentially forced him to change ironic
since he's used to forcing himself on
others while on the phone with Cara he
even thinks her and addresses her as
ma'am we also get this great shot of
Peter looking at the painting of a stag
where the painting Abeka used to be only
when he has transformed as a person can
he become the stag a noble creature
known to symbolise fatherhood grace and
wisdom earlier in the film Peter watches
the stag from afar only now he is face
to face with it and the stag symbolizing
fatherhood is interesting because he
then goes to visit his daughter and
ex-wife apologizing to both of them for
the mistakes he's made in the past and
promising his daughter he'll always be
there for her it's also interesting to
note that all the animals in this film
are male only male peacocks have the
colored plumage peacocks are known for
only males are bumblebee drones and only
male goats have horns that size a
particular note about the goat is how it
can be seen pissing just like how Peter
will later piss himself the goat is also
commonly used as a symbol of Satanism
and the occult which leads to my next
point
the witch's art really which is the
entire plan was concocted as revenge for
Becca's death and the hope that Peter
would change this meant fake stakes
through his hands charges that made the
windows of winds car explode and even
electronic clicker that could turn the
stove on and off Peters paralysis was
caused by him being drugged in his
hallucinations such as the snake was
likely a result of that as well what's
never really explained are their flame
hands which I can only assume was the
drugs or some sort of pyrotechnic it's
also ironic that the women dress him up
in Becca's clothes and apply makeup
turning him into the thing he
disrespects most a woman now he is the
one to be objectified ridiculed and made
to feel less he has become
each woman here also has their own
reason for getting back at Peter Lilith
for example was the mother of a girl who
was sexually assaulted and no one
believed her claims Elena's mother was
fired by Peter and given unequal wages
there's also a big connection to
spirituality all the women have tattoos
that look similar to the Celtic
triquetra symbol or Celtic knot it
represents unity and spirit much like
the unity of their sisterhood they also
wear creepy masts reminiscent of ancient
tribal masks but their main purpose is
just a freak peter out and let's talk
about Lonnie Agnes and Peter's father
this painting here is heavily implied in
the trailer as being that of peter's
father a self-portrait always watching
over him we learned that he died years
ago and that Peter wasn't invited to the
funeral likely because of the
allegations against him but it's never
explicitly said in the film just like
how Peters estrangement from his ex-wife
could be because of those allegations or
that he simply wasn't a good husband and
father what we do find out is that Agnes
and Peter's father had an affair with
Lonnie being their son that would
technically make him Peter's
half-brother there were also a few
elements to this story that have no
explanation but were put in there just
to up the spooky factor this includes
the insect infestation
Agnes's tongue and the blood in the
toilet these felt a bit cheap to me
because the spookiness had nothing to do
with the plot they were simply added for
the sake of making things weird instead
of for the sake of the story and finally
we have this mystery woman at the end
who has the same tattoo as the other
women this works on two levels as a nice
sting to end the movie but also as a
reminder to Peter that someone will
always be watching him but I want to
know what you thought about tree house
in the comments below make sure to LIKE
and subscribe and if you haven't checked
out my videos on new year new you down
or puka give it a look and remember
daddy loves you very much